another thing that if you slept with a
certain number of people 10 people or
whatever the number is you're a hoe it's
just just you're just you okay and
unfortunately for me I don't want a
woman that has slept with 20 men
so now we both get to move on our
separate ways and I will find my person
eventually so it's not like it doesn't
matter nobody I don't care how many
people you slept with you slept with one
you slept with 25 whatever that is your
business I have a choice okay to say I
want to be with you or I don't and
that's it but you want people the whole
question here was why do women lie they
lie because there's a stigma on how many
people you slept with that's why they
lie because
whatever the reason whatever the reason
you may think it is whatever it is but
to me that's the reason why I feel that
a lot of women lie no Society has told
us that men do not want because there's
plenty of men there there's men that
want women with no kids Society told you
if a man can protect you he's not a man
either and y'all believe that right so
what are we talking about
it's women women don't like what they
qualify for oh and my thing is I agree
with you a lot of women do not qualify
for the men that they want
okay a lot of women they don't qualify
because they want I want this I want
this I want this I want this I want a
man that loves me I want to have money I
want him to be seven feet tall I want
him to be all these things and I agree a
lot of women do not qualify okay but I'm
not gonna call you a name and call you a
[ __ ] and call you this and that because
you slept with a certain number of
people because you're not going to come
and tell me the truth just like a man
they'd be lying left and right about
anything because sometimes they just
want to be Liars they just want to lie
for no reason okay and that's fine but
it's my choice do I want someone that
lies to me
no I don't want someone that lives
because then that means that I can't
trust you and to me trust is important
but I if you lied to me and I find out
you lie one or two times I'm not gonna
ask you are you a liar
because I already know you a liar
and you know what it's my choice to not
be with you anymore and that's it
everyone has a choice if I tell you I
slept with however many people it is
your choice to not want to be with me
if I have friends that have slept with
so many people it is my choice to not
want to be their friend is but I'm not
going to go in and tell them oh you're
this and that so in the future you won't
be truthful towards me like what's the
point do you think entertainment does
skew your like I don't think the women
in general and Society are as bad as
like freshness like I know what
entertainment like I'm always trying to
get the most controversial guess like I
agree with you the reason we go to the
extreme is to prove a point
so it's to say like maybe she didn't
have only fans but she slept with 20
dudes or 10 dudes but like I honestly I
interview guys this I asked the question
how many bodies is Too Many Bodies it
seems to be right around 10 but if I
push it and I say okay 11 12. they're
usually it seems like the real number is
15 for men
like but I'm different because obviously
you know I got to be realistic but guys
guys okay this is a more of a fair guy
and I know my body count well I don't
know it but this is the thing the guys
have a towel too like women have a tell
if they have a lot of bodies because
they'll argue for body count no offense
but like men have a tell too if they say
like too low I'm like you don't get
[ __ ] yeah
[Music]
like that's a fact like I told her just
now like I know my body I gotta give you
at least 20. like but like all right but
the thing is like also men kind of cap
on camera too is the other thing like
they'll say 10 but if I push it and
because I always push it because
everyone lies like though like in the
camera right so I'll be like 10 then I
say 15. and I'm like all right what
about 17 would you if she has everything
and they're like well I'll be honest
with you right pearl since since you
called out guys on cabin I'll be a
hundred percent honest with you yeah
well I'm always honest I got the name
hundo but like so there was a girl who
we had
um a one night stand sexual fling right
I really wasn't a one-night stand
because I was supposed to hit it but
then I didn't hit it and then she left
on vacation when she came back the day
she came back I hit it so whatever now
stand too nice to end right so now in
the second night right when I'm hitting
it literally she starts like crying and
I'm like what the [ __ ] like like this is
not what I wanted
and
I'm like are you okay and she's like
yeah like because you know I'm all big
on consent and then she's like yeah you
know but like I'm just upset mind you I
was 20 years old she was 19. okay she's
like you're my 10th guy
and that was like a big number to me and
I already made mistakes in my past and
I'm actually upset that I'm making the
same one right so I was like damn 10 you
probably just started clapping like
three years ago you're bugging right but
you said that no no I'm saying in my
head so now what ends up what ended up
happening I was in a two-year
relationship with her right year and a
half whatever so the thing was the fact
that she was so honest with me
I was like all right you know what
it was also a digestible number right
I'm not gonna lie because if she did say
25 and 19 I'm 20 it'd be an automatic
dub but I knew that you know when my
body cow I was over 10 so I'm like you
know what it's not that bad tennis not
that bad
and and I gave her a chance and you know
we we had a good relationship whatever
and it ended
now
I think that the thing is a lot of women
are ashamed of their body count because
it's not a realistic number
see
me being me being a tenth guy and her
having nine previous
right now I believe she's engaged and
she could be at 11. okay maybe 12.
that's an acceptable number you know
what the average amount of men that
women sleep with in America by time to
get married is 11.
that's the number's 11.
that's realistic right in America so now
what what happened go ahead Pearl
um yeah the problem is with the I the
problem is with those stats is that it's
um they include people from like the
older generation
so so all right so there is a variable
it's probably higher because the the
thing is like in any stat like yeah the
medium they're taking the media you want
to do I think it's like the mean where
it's the most common number I don't know
what that is but so which is true but
let's just rock with what we got for now
right sorry like I'm too no no we could
go on variables on on these on these
stats right but but the average they say
the average they say is 11 Men by time
they get married making I would assume
the the man that they married at 12 men
even though I don't really rock with 12
right but
women know when it's too much okay
women know when they've had too many
partners
and they automatically grow ashamed to
it and if there are this amount of
abundance of women that had that number
that is bigger than 12 okay if 12 is the
realistic number that most women you
know in the median standpoint are
getting married a body count that
they're getting married then it is what
it is
but if you tell me 25 which is double
and you're 25. but is that based on just
your experience of that one situation no
my thing is that we got to understand
what I know men more than women know men
I don't care what a woman says right I
know the man that you're dealing with I
know the man like because I can I could
tell what type of man he is only a man
can tell what type of man he is just
like only a woman can tell what type of
woman she is you just get fooled
you're gullible or you're easily bought
it's one of the two there's only one
reason why you're having sex I mean
there's only a few reasons why you're
having sex with multiple men you're not
having sex with multiple men because you
truly want to and any woman that does is
truly broken
there's no way a woman is going to have
sex with 50 men and say that that's what
they want to do and I would say there's
an anomaly I'm going I'm not talking
about the exceptional purpose I'm
talking about the majority of women do
not want to have sex with multiple men
majority of women do not want to have an
old man a young man a 100 old men or
young men on top of them breathing heavy
no woman wants that who do you want that
Marie boy I'll write that do you want
that Lonnie no and women don't want
women women do not want listen on my
part I'm getting I'm getting passing it
women do not want
no women women do not want hundreds of
men tens of men breathing on top of them
heavily penetrating them I don't presume
to know what other women want Marie just
caught me up because Maria is an
equalist I don't presume to know what
other women want no I don't want I don't
want a thousand women saying that they
wrote me either I got more respect for
myself now I don't want a thousand women
riding me either because like yo at the
same time it's like yo like I I value
myself so much that I don't like and
this is why I had to slow down my own
self because I don't like when women can
be like yo that's group chat Rico we all
got him and I'm like all right well it
was cool for me and it was cool for
y'all but y'all all hoes guess what the
chances of me getting the relationship I
want I'm not married not just a marriage
the chances of me getting the marriage
that I want and desire is higher than
theirs things matter for a reason like
there's a reason things matter in
society we didn't evolve to this point
to like go against what's natural like
there's a reason that things matter
biologically yeah like look at okay look
at the Rays of of scds right now
what do you think this is all men yeah
men can't do it by themselves if 80 of
women are sexually active we're only
um like or 66 or two out of three men
are roughly yeah because at the same
time what the stat is about 30 of men
are actually desirable yeah so if you
had 30 percent of men that are actually
desirable that means women have to be
realistic and be like you're sharing the
same man I don't want to say every girl
but nowadays like
situationships are first and so that's
like you're starting as a side chick and
then you get to see if you make it to
the final round and whoever yeah look
bro that's how I got my daughter like we
was like it was a long story like you
know but I'm not gonna get into that but
at the same time that is true at the end
of the day what we got to do is we got
to make conscious decisions and I think
that people need to understand that no
matter I don't I don't care how you feel
okay
consequences are inevitable and so so is
categorizing all right if you do things
that pertain to certain categories you
need to take what comes with it if you
don't want to wear that shoe don't walk
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible